اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات في العناوين
اوكرانيا تشن معركه داخليه ضد الفساد
يعترف بصعوبه الوضع على جبهات القتال
[موسيقى]
روسيا تحتفل بذكرى هزيمه الالمان ورئيس
المخابرات يقول لن نحارب حتى اخر اوكراني
طهران تنشر سفينتين عسكريتين في البرازيل
و واشنطن تراقب تحركات في امريكا
اللاتينيه
واستم مخاوف متزايده بشان توغل الصين
واشنطن ومنالا توسعان الوجود العسكري في
الفلبين
احييكم البدايه من تطورات الحرب
الاوكرانيه حيث حذر وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
من ان روسيا تستعد لهجوم كبير جديد على
بلاده وكشف انه قد يبدا في اقرب وقت ممكن
بحلول الرابع والعشرين من فبراير الجاري
وقال ان موسكو حشدت الالاف من القوات
ويمكنها تجربه شيء ما بحلول الذكرى
السنويه الاولى للغزو وسيصادف الهجوم ايضا
يوم المدافع او المدافع عن ارض الاباء في
الثالث والعشرين من فبراير والذي يحتفي به
بالجيش الروسي كل عام واكد ريزنكوب ان
موسكو حشدت نحو 500 الف جندي لتنفيذ هذا
الهجوم
تصريحاته وزير الدفاع الاوكراني تتماهى مع
تحذير لمعهد دراسات الحرب الامريكي الذي
حذر من نيات روسيا اجراء عمليه هجوميه
حاسمه في دومباس متوقعا ان يحدث ذلك في
الشهر الحالي او الشهر المقبل المعهد ايضا
اشار مشاهدينا الى ان الحاله السيئه
للمعدات العسكريه الروسيه ستجبر القياده
العسكريه الروسيه على حشد المزيد من
القوات حتى تتفوق على عدد القوات
الاوكرانيه من اجل تحقيق المزيد من
المكاسب على ارض المعركه وسوف تركز جهودها
على تاكيد سيطرتها على كامل دونيسك وعلى
ايضا الرئيس الاوكراني بدوره فولدمير
اعترف في تقييم عسكري بان الوضع على خطوط
الاماميه في شرق البلاد يزداد صعوبه مع
تكثيف القوات الروسيه هجومها زيلينسكي
اشاره في خطابه للمسائي المصور الى ان
هناك زياده مؤكده في العمليات الهجوميه
للقوات الروسيه على الجبهه في شرق البلاد
مضيفا ان الروسي يحاولون
الى العدو الداخلي على حد قوله وللمزيد من
التفاصيل ينضم الينا من كيف مراسل العربيه
حذيفه عادل اهلا بك معنا او حذيفه اذا
لنبدا بتصريحات زيلينسكي وقلقه من هذا
التقدم الروسي في الشرق الاوكراني كيف
تتناول الصحف في الداخل والخبراء
والمحللين هذه التصريحات من الرئيس
تحياتي فاطمه يعني التقدم الروسي في الشرق
وتحديدا في منطقه دونيسك هو واقع الان
يعني اقر به
الرئيسكي وكبار القاده في الجيش الاوكراني
كذلك يعني تاتينا المعلومات طباعا من
جبهات القتال من مصادرنا في جبهات القتال
التي تتحدث عن يعني هجمات واسعه وعمليات
اقتحام كبيره يقوم بها جيش الاتحاد الروسي
تحديدا في منطقه دونسك هذه الهجمات وهذا
هذه الاقتحامات التي تقوم بها القوات
الروسيه هي في بعض المناطق يعني يعني تؤدي
الى السيطره على مراكز قليله حول مدينه
باق والتحديدا ولكن الهدف الرئيسي هو
الضغط على القوات داخل مدينه باكموت
لاجبارها على الانسحاب ما يتناوله داخل
الاوكراني ما يتناوله الخبراء العسكريين
وكذلك المحللين حول هذا الامر طبعا ان
الروس يركزون لي قبل نهايه او قبل الذكرى
او حتى في هذه الفتره القريبه ان يسيطروا
على منطقه
بالكامل للفراغ لمناطق اخرى كالجنوب ثم
بعد ذلك تحقيق تقدم في منطقه خرسون وغير
ذلك طبعا الان التركيز الاساسي على دونسك
وعلى اذا تحدثنا عن لوغانست فالقوات
الروسيه الان تقوم بحجز كبير جدا للقوه
للمعدات في منطقه لوغاز هي لا تحقق تقدما
على الارض ولكنها تحسد الموارد القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول التقدم ولكن تقدمها الذي
اعلنت عنه بطيء جدا بسبب عمليات الزرع
الالغام الواسعه في تلك المنطقه والتي
يعني تحول دون التقدم بسرعه اكبر في منطقه
لوكاس اما في كما افادت القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه وكذلك انا استمعت الى شهادات
من عدد من الجنود في الجبل الذين يقولون
ان الاعداد كبيره المشكله الاساسيه
الاساسيه الان هو الهجوم باعداد كبيره جدا
من قبل القوات الروسيه يقولون ايضا
حذيفه على دنيتك ولا تقدم يعني
اسالك عن
المعارك التي يعملها يعملها في الحكومه
الداخليه في اوكرانيا هل من اسباب ذكرت
حول هذا
التصفيه التي يقوم بها ربما
نعم في الحقيقه هنالك اسباب واسباب
موضوعيه جدا اولا قضايا الفساد التي ظهرت
في الداخل الاوكراني زيلينسكي يحاول ان
يعني ان يجعل الجبهه الداخليه متماسكه
وهنا العنصر الاساسي في ذلك الشعب اذا غضب
الشعب على الحكومه والشعر بفساد الحكومه
هذا الامر سوف يزعزع الجبهه الداخليه
للدوله الاوكرانيه وفي الحقيقه هذا هو
الركيز الاساسيه التي تعتمد عليها السلطات
الاوكرانيه
لمجابهه هذه الحرب فهو يحاول اولا ان يرضي
الداخل يحاول ان يقضي على الفساد داخل
الحكومه ولكن هنالك هدف استراتيجي اخر
طبعا الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
تعلمين ان غدا سوف تكون القمه الاوروبيه
مع رئيس المجلس الاوروبي والرئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه وهذه القمه الهدف
الرئيسي والاساسي منها سيحاول الجانب
الاوكراني ان ينتزع تقدما في عمليه
التكامل الاوروبي والانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي من اهم الشروط ذلك هو مكافحه
الفساد الان الدوله الاوكرانيه حزب الرئيس
وناديمير حزب قادم الشعب على لسان رئيس
الحزب قال بشكل واضح ان المسؤولين اذا لم
يتكيفوا مع الوضع الجديد ويفهموا ان
الامور قد تغيرت وانه لن يكون هنالك فرصه
لاي شخص لاي عمليات فساد واذا لم يتغيروا
بنفسهم سوف تساعدهم الدوله على التغيير
وذلك في اشاره الى العمليات التي يقوم بها
جهاز الامن الوطني الاوكراني تجاه
المسؤولين داخل الدوله وكذلك باعتبار رجال
الاعمال الان السلطات تقوم بعمليات يعني
تفتيش وعمليات مراجعه حتى لكبار رجال
الاعمال في الدوله شكرا لك من كيف مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل
روسيا تقيم عرضا عسكريا في مدينه فولكراد
وبذلك بمناسبه مرور 80 عاما على معركه
شتالينغاد بين الجيشين السوفيتي والالماني
ومن المقرر ان يلقي الرئيس الروسي كلمه
خلال العرض العسكري الذي ياتي في وقت تشهد
موسكو صراعا كبيرا مع الغرب
ورئيس جهاز الاستخبارات الخارجيه الروسيه
اعلن ان الولايات المتحده تنفق المزيد
والمزيد من الطاقه في محاوله للحفاظ على
وحده دول النيتو للعدوان على روسيا وتواجه
واشنطن الشركاء المشككين في الحلف بالحاجه
لمحاربه روسيا وتضعهم في مكانهم بحزم على
حد قول نارجيكين الذي اضاف مشاهدينا
بالمقابل ان معظم سكان اوكرانيا اشخاص
عاديون يريدون ان يعيشوا حياه سليمه لكنهم
اصبحوا ضحايا للسياسه العدوانيه لحلف شمال
الاطلسي مؤكدا ان روسيا لا تريد خوض حرب
حتى اخر اوكرانيا ودعونا نشير الى هذا
العاجل امامنا على الشاشه مشاهدينا والذي
تحدث عن التطورات الميدانيه في المعركه
ومن موسكو حاول المزيد تنضم الينا مراسله
العربيه كاتيا طعم اهلا بك معنا كاتيا اذا
حذيفه عادل مراسلنا
الاعداد المتزايده للقوات الروسيه هي التي
ادت لهذا التقدم بحسب الانباء الاوكرانيه
في الشرق الاوكراني عن ماذا تتحدث الانباء
في الداخل الروسي
مرحبا فاطمه بالفعل هناك تقدم نشهده
بالفتره الاخيره للقوات الروسيه طبعا هي
ليست لوحدها هناك بمشاركه من قوات فارغنال
الخاصه والقوات الانفصاليه كنا شاهدنا
خلال الفتره الاخيره تقدما كبيرا طبعا هذا
ما تحدثت عنه هو تناولته الصحف الروسيه
اليوم بانه كان تقدم طاله انتظاره من قبل
الجانب الروسي تحقيق هذه المكاسب من قبل
القوات الروسيه في الفتره الاخيره هو طبعا
طال انتظاره من قبل الشعب الروسي والشارع
الروسي ايضا كنا قد شهدنا اليوم ايضا منذ
الصباح تحدثت الدفاع الروسي انها قامت
بفضل قوات الانزال الروسيه بصد محاوله
هجوم للقوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه سواتو
وكريمانيا ادت الى هروب هذه القوات
الاوكرانيه لذلك كما قلت لك هناك ترحيب
بهذا التقدم الذي اعتبره بعض الخبراء
العسكريين انه فيما بعد قد يكون نقطه
التحول في هذه المعركه
بحسب الخبراء العسكريين في موسكو
وبحسب لافروف وفي هذا العاجل على الشاشه
يقول بان الغربيه يسعى لهزيمه
استراتيجيه لروسيا لا تتعافى منها لعقود
ماذا عن تصريحات لظروف الاخيره هل من مزيد
من تصريحات
او وزير الخارجيه الروسي اولا قال ان
الجميع ينتظر انتهاء العمليه العسكريه
ولكن العمل الوقت ليس هو العامل الرئيسي
في هذه العمليه العسكريه طبعا او انهاء
المعركه لان الغرب في حال استمر بتزويده
بتزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح هذا يعني ان
روسيا ستضطر الى الدفع بالحدود او
بالمسافه الامان كما يقال عن حدودها في
حال كيف حصلت على مزيد من الاسلحه وطبعا
هو تعليقا على تصريحات المستشار الالماني
الذي قال ان المانيا لن تقوم بتزويد كيف
بمقاتلات هو قال ان مستشار الالماني هو
لطالما يقوم بتغيير رايه بشكل مستمر لذلك
لا يوجد ضمانات بان المانيا ايضا لن تقوم
فيما بعد بارسال مقاتلات الى الى اوكرانيا
بعد طبعا قرارها بارسال دبابات لوبارد
الذي اتخذته منذ فتره قليله طبعا فاطمه
طيب اذا لنذكر بهذه العواجل كاتيا التي
اتت من لافروف كما اشرت حيث قال ان الغرب
يسعى لهزيم استراتيجيه لروسيا لا تتعافى
منها لعقود واضاف ان كلما تزود اوكرانيا
او تزود باسلحه غربيه وجب ابعادها عن
الاراضي الروسيه وان الاجراءات الغربيه
تلعب دورا مهما كاتيا كيفيه سير العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا لافروف اضاف
ايضا ان جميع الاطراف تريد انهاء الصراع
في اوكرانيا وطبعا لا ننسى ايضا تعليق
بوتين عندما قال اننا لن نقاتل او نحارب
الى اخر جندي اوكراني كيف فهم المحللون في
داخل الروسي كاتيا هذه التصريحات للرئيس
بوتين كذلك
يعني الشارع الروسي او كما تعتبر موسكو ان
الغرب يحاول هزيمه روسيا وذلك على حساب
اوكرانيا يعني حتى اخر اوكرانيا كما تقول
موسكو ولكن روسيا تعتبر انها طبعا هي
مستعده للجلوس الى طاوله المحادثات في حال
طبعا وجدت هذه الرغبه لدى الجانب
الاوكراني وكما قال منذ قليل وزير
الخارجيه الروسي ان الغرب قادر على ان
اراد ان ينهي هذه الازمه هو قادر الان ان
ينهيها بان يقوم بدفع زيلينسكي او الجانب
الاوكراني الى طاوله المحادثات ولكن هذه
الرغبه لا توجد لدى الغرب وانزلنسكي فقط
هو يحرك من قبل
الغرب ومن قبل واشنطن لذلك حتى الان لا
يوجد اي رغبه في الجلوس الى طاوله
المحادثات لانهاء هذه المعركه وبالتالي
سيضطر او سيكون هناك طبعا محاوله لهزيمه
روسيا استراتيجيا على حساب الشعب الشعب
الاوكراني والقوات الاوكرانيه التي طبعا
تستنزف من قبل
هذه المعركه التي تجري على اراضيها الان
اذا لا جلوس على طاوله المفاوضات حتى
يوافق الجانب الغربي على ذلك شكرا لك من
موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا
قال وهو قائد سابق في مجموعه قال ان
الاوضاع الميدانيه في بخموت سيئه وان
الطرق هناك مليئه بجثث جنود فاجنر
كانت الطرق المؤديه الى باخمه مليئه بجثه
جنودنا وهناك خسائر فادحه الاوضاع لم تكن
جيده عندما وصلنا الى مركز التدريب
واخرجوا المتطوعين الى الساحات شاهدت
عناصر من اجهزه الامن التابعه لفاجنر
ومعهم اثنين من الذين رفضوا القتال قالوا
انهم خونه وقتلوهما بالرصاص
القائد السابق في فاجنر وصف رئيس المجموعه
الحالي بانه شخص مريض ويجب عزله مشيرا الى
انه سيامر باطلاق النار على الناس بشكل
عشوائي حاله حصوله على السلطه
من الواضح ان رئيس مجموعه فاجنر شخص مريض
ويجب عزله فهو يسعى للسلطه من خلال طرد
حاكم منطقه لينينغراد ليحل مكانه يمكن ان
نتخيل اذا اصبح هذا الشخص حاكما سيامر
باطلاق النار على الناس ماذا سيحدث في
البلد مستقبلا هل سنبدا بشنق الناس في
الساحات الحمراء
في هولندا اعلنت السلطات الامنيه ان
قراصنه الكترونيين موالينا رولز لروسيا
يقفون على الارجح خلف هجوم سيبرانيين
استهدف مستشفيات في هولندا وايضا دول
اوروبيه اخرى تدعم اوكرانيا وقال جهاز
مكافحه الجرائم الالكترونيه الهولندي ان
مستشفى في غون بنك الشمالة هولندا تعطل
موقعه الالكتروني جراء هجوم من الكتروني
سيبراني فيما اوضح المركز الوطني الهولندي
للامن السيبراني اوامر الهجمات نفذتها على
الارجح مجموعه القرصنه المواليه لروسيا
كلنات ضد بلدان اوروبيه تدعم اوكرانيا كما
اعلنت مستشفيات في بريطانيا المانيا
بولندا والدول الاسكندنافيه والولايات
المتحده ايضا انها تعرضت لهجمات قرصنه
الكترونيه مماثله الرئيس او رئيس الدمى
الروسي شدد على ان الدبابات الالمانيه في
اوكرانيا ستواجه نفس المصير قبل 80 عاما
في اشاره الى معركه لينقراد ضد النازيه
الالمانيه التي تحتفل روسيا بذكرها اليوم
لكن قبل ذلك قال وزير الدفاع الالماني
بوريس دستوريوس اثناء زيارته لسريه الجيش
حيث توجد دبابات 2 التي تجهز للارسال
لاوكرانيا قال ان برلين تطلب انتاج دبابات
ليوبار جديده لتعويض الدبابات التي
سترسلها المانيا الى كيف
الحقيقه الحاسمه انه يتعين علينا طلب
دبابات جديده ليس في غضون ام بل باسرع وقت
حتى يمكن بدء الانتاج ويمكننا التخطيط متى
سيكون لدينا عدد دبابات الجديده من اين
ستاتي الاموال دعني اتحدث بصراحه عن هذا
السؤال بصراحه لا اهتم الامر نفسه ينطبق
على امدادات الذخيره اعاده الامداد
المستمر امر مهم وكذلك فيما يتعلق بمساله
مدافعها والمركبه المدرعه الاخرى
[موسيقى]
في عرض ملفت ومغرن مسيرتان بدولار واحد
فقط عرض امريكي لاوكرانيا لمساعدتها في
الدفاع عن نفسها في الوقت الذي تستعد
لمواجهه هجوم روسيا جديد متوقع قبيل
الربيع المقبل المزيد مع الزميله ليال
مسيرتان بدولار واحد فقط عرض امريكي
لاوكرانيا لمساعده الاخيره بالدفاع عن
نفسها في الوقت الذي تستعد فيه لهجوم روسي
متوقع قبيل الربيع المقبل فوفقا الامريكيه
شركه جنرال اتوميكس الامريكيه التي تعتبر
من اكبر الشركات للصناعات العسكريه في
العالم عرضت على وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
بيع كل طائرتين من دون طيار من طراز
مقابل دولار واحد الصفقه ستتطلب منك انفاق
حوالي عشره ملايين دولار لاعاده وشحن
الطائرات الى اوكرانيا وحوالي ثمانيه
ملايين دولار الى لكل عام لصيانه هذه
الطائرات من دون طبعا طيار القديمه والتي
لا يتم استخدامها حاليا في اوكرانيا العرض
يشمل ايضا محطه تحكم ارضيه لتشغيل
الطائرات من دون طيار في اي مكان على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وفقا لرساله الصحيفه
الامريكيه انها طلعت عليها مسيرات هي
ريبار ليست مسلحه ولكن يمكن حملها في
حقيبه على الظهر وتستخدم لتصطدم بالاهداف
يبلغ طول جناحي
حوالي 66 قدما ويمكن تصليحها كما يمكنها
ايضا ان تطير لاكثر من اربعه وعشرين ساعه
البيت الابيض الذي سيتعين عليه الموافقه
على صفقه البيع رفضت التعليق على الامر
حتى الان واشنطن كانت قد قدمت في العام
الماضي اكثر من 700 طائره من دون طيار
اصغر الى اوكرانيا بما في ذلك طائرات من
دون طيار تكتيكيه من طراز
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها
خطه امنيه امريكيه لتهدئه التوتر في الضفه
الغربيه والجيش الاسرائيلي يرد على اطلاق
صاروخ ويجن غارات جويه على قطاع غزه
احييكم من جديد صغت الولايات المتحده خطه
امنيه لاعاده سيطره القوات الامنيه
التابعه للسلطات الفلسطينيه على شمال
الضفه الغربيه وذلك طبعا بهدف تهدئه
التوتر في المنطقه وفق موقع اكسيوس ونقل
الموقع ايضا عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين
وامريكيين قولهم ان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي ضغط على رئيس السلطه الفلسطينيه
محمود عباس في رام الله الثلاثاء وذلك
لقبول وتنفيذ الخطه الامنيه التي صاغها
المنسقه الامنيه الامريكي الجنرال مايكل
بهدف اعاده سيطره السلطه الفلسطينيه على
مدينتي جنين ونابلس الجيش الاسرائيلي قال
انه نفذ ضربات جويه في قطاع غزه فجر
الخميس وذلك بعد ساعات من اعتراضه صاروخا
اطلق من القطاع باتجاه مستوطنات حدوديه
ولم ترد تقارير بعد عن وقوع ضحايا تطور
مشاهدينا ياتي في اعقاب حث الولايات
المتحده جميع الاطراف على وقف العنف
المتصاعد اسرائيل والفلسطينيين الجيش
الاسرائيلي اوضح ان ضرباته الجويه استهدفت
مواقع صناعه الصواريخ والاسلحه التي
تستخدمها حركه حماس والتي تدير القطاع
المحاصر وذلك ردا على اطلاق صاروخ
الاربعاء وهزه انفجارات قويه المباني
واضاءه ظلمه الليل في سماء غزه بينما دوت
صافرات الانذار من جديد في مناطق
اسرائيليه حول القطاع للتحذير من قدوم
مزيد من الصواريخ قد تستهدف مناطق
اسرائيليه حول القطاع ومقاطع فيديو اظهرت
مشاهدينا صورا لغالات لغارات اسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه جنتها اسرائيل بعد ساعات من
اعلان الجيش اعتراض صواريخ اطلقت من هذا
القطاع وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي حول ذلك
فرقه تعمل على التاكيد انما اطلق من
القطاع تجاه المستوطنات صواريخ ام مضادات
ارض ارضيه
[موسيقى]
للحديث عن مزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي اهلا بك معنا
زياد بعد اسبوع من تبادل القصف بين
الجانبين تاتي هذه الجوله فما تفاصيلها
هذا صحيح كما اسلفتي في المقدمه المطوله
عمليا كان هناك اطلاق صاروخ ومن ثم الجيش
الاسرائيلي شن فجرا غارات قال انها طالت
مواقع من بينها موقعان عمليا لتخزين
وانتاج الاسلحه وسط قطاع غزه وجنوبي مدينه
غزه بعدها ايضا اطلقت طبعا صواريخ مضاده
للطائرات من قبل كتائب القسام وهذا اقرت
به اسرائيل ايضا بالاضافه الى المضادات
الارضيه واطلقت سته صواريخ ايضا تجاه
المستوطنات الحدوديه الاسرائيليه عمليا
وهذا كان عباره عن يعني كانت عباره عن
جوله محدوده من تبادل القصف ولكن بدون ان
شك هي تاتي بعد اسبوع فقط على الجوله
الاخيره عمليا قبل اسبوع عندما اطلق اطلقت
عشره صواريخ من قطاع غزه تجاه المستوطنات
الاسرائي
طيب زياد يعني هل من اسباب متداوله حول
هذا التصعيد المتكرر بين الجانبين رغم
المحاولات الامريكيه للتهدئه
يعني بالامس توقعنا بشكل واضح بان يكون
هناك رد على الصاروخ وان يطلق اساسا
الصاروخ لسبب بسيط لانه وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي المتطرفه
على اجراءات في اكثر من اتجاه ضاغطه على
الفلسطينيين ومستفزه في كثير من الاحيان
بالامس مثلا كان هناك عمليه قمع في سجن
الدامون للاسيرات الفلسطينيه الجهاد
الاسلامي هددت فورا بانها سترد على هذا
الموضوع وهذا ما حصل اطلق الصاروخ بسبب
هذا الامر حتى ان بنجفير سارى الى ربط ما
حدث
بموضوع الاسرى وقال انه يصر على الاجراءات
داخل الاقسام ضد الاسرى واساءه ظروف
اعتقالهم عمليا ولهذا التوقعات في اسرائيل
بان حرب شامله على قطاع غزه هي فقط مساله
وقت لا اكثر طيب زياده هل هناك ربما
محاولات اقليميه او المصريه للتهدئه او
لتقريب وجهات النظر
هناك دائما
يعني امر يتكرر بشكل رتيب ومنهجي وهو
تشتعل الامور كثيرا او قليلا على جبهات
قطاع غزه فتضع مصر يدها دائما في محاولات
الوساطه هي بالاساس استادعت امس قيادي
الجهاد الاسلامي الى القاهره للقاء
المخابرات المصريه ومن ثم اتبعت ذلك
بطلب ايضا لقاء مسؤولين من حماس اليوم في
القاهره بهدف احتواء الوضع لانها باتت
تدرك بان الموضوع بات مرتبط وهذا ايضا ما
يقلق الاسرائيليين كثيرا وهو ربط الجبهات
او الساحات بعضها ببعض بمعنى توتر في
الضفه الغربيه يقود الى عمليات في القدس
يقود الى تفعيل جبهه غزه وهكذا والعكس
بالعكس
هذه التطورات هل هناك قلق او مخاوف من ان
تندلع حرب جديده في القطاع زياد
هذا صحيح جدا عمليا ان استمرت هذه الامور
على هذه الشاكله يبدو بانها ثمه تقدما
بثقه تجاه حرب جديده على قطاع غزه فقط
للتذكير رمضان الماضي انشاء اندلعت حرب
على قطاع غزه كان سببها نائب اسمه ايتامار
من غير المستبعد في رمضان المقبل ان يتكرر
الامر مع وزير اسمه اتمار شكرا لك من
القدس مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي مشاهدينا يتوجه
الى فرنسا اليوم في اول زياره رسميه له
منذ عودته الى السلطه
نياهو الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
وزياره الممتده لثلاثه ايام تتزامن مع
تصعيد في اعمال العنف بين الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين
متحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه اكد
في تصريحات اوردتها شبكه فوكس نيوز ان
واشنطن على درايه بتحركات البحريه
الايرانيه وذلك قرب سواحل امريكا
اللاتينيه مشيرا الى ان واشنطن تراقب
محاولات طهران لاقامه وجود عسكري في النصف
الغربي من الكره الارضيه وسبت الماضي
افادت صحيفه طهران تايمز نقل عن نائب قائد
القوات البحريه الايرانيه بان الاسطول 86
التابع للقوات البحريه الايرانيه يبحر
الان على طول السواحل الغربيه لامريكا
اللاتينيه الشبكه الامريكيه اوضحت ان
التدخل العسكري للنظام الايراني في ممر
النقل البحري الحيوي لقناه بنما سيلحق
الضرر بالتجاره الامريكيه وسيؤدي الى توتر
السوق الاقتصاديه العالميه صفير ايران لدى
الامم المتحده اتهم اسرائيل بالوقوف وراء
هجوم بالمسيرات في اصفهان جنوب طهران وكان
مسؤولون ايرانيون اعلنوا عن احباط محاوله
هجوم من قبل ثلاث طائرات مس استهدفت مصنعا
للذخيره في مدينه اصفهان حيث احبطت واحده
او احبطت وانفجرت الطائرتان الاخريتان
ونبقى في ايران والى الاحتجاجات ضد نظام
فيران حيث نزل اهالي فولاد شهر في اصفهان
في الشوارع للاحتجاج مرددين شعارات مناوئه
للنظام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واظهر ايضا مقطع فيديو اخر ترديد اهالي
اصفهان لشعار وراء كل قتيل الف شخص وذلك
ضمن الاحتجاجات ضد النظام الايراني
[موسيقى]
ننتقل بكم مشاهدينا مباشره الى روسيا حيث
يدلي وزير الخارجيه الروسي بتصريحات
لوسائل اعلام روسيا رافروف قال بان الغرب
يسعى لهزيمه استراتيجيه لروسيا طبعا لا
تتعافى منها لعقود وان كلما كلما تزود
اوكرانيا باسلحه غربيه وجب ابعادها عن
الاراضي الروسيه لافروف اشار في تصريحاته
لوسائل الاعلام الروسيه بان اجراءات الغرب
تلعب دورا مهما في كيفيه سير العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا طبعا اشاره
الى ان الغرب هم من يحملون القرار لما
يحدث على الارض في اوكرانيا وان الجانبان
يريدان انهاء الصراع في اوكرانيا ولكن
يبدو ان لا تنازلات يعني شتى تشهدها
المعارك حتى الان
عوده الى سياق نشرتنا بحث ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان ووزيره
خارجيه فرنسا
التي تزور الرياض بحث اخر المستجدات
الاقليميه والدوليه والجهود المبذوله
تجاهها كما استعرض ولي العهد السعودي
والوزير الفرنسيه العلاقات الثنائيه بين
الرياض وباريس وسبل تعزيزها طبعا وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه من دوره الامير فيصل بن
فرحان طبعا يقوم بزياره رسميه الى العاصمه
العراقيه بغداد يلتقي خلالها بنظيره
العراقي فؤاد حسين والرئاسات الثلاث
للحكومه والجمهوريه والبرلمان ومن المرتقب
ايضا عقد مؤتمر صحفيين يجمع وزيري
الخارجيه السعودي والعراقي مساء اليوم حول
ذلك ينضم الينا من بغداد مراسل العربيه
ماجد حميد اهلا بك معنا ماجد اذا ما
التفاصيل والمعلومات الوارده لديك حول هذه
الزياره واهميتها في هذا التوقيت تحديدا
والتي تشهد فيها العراق انتهاكات لسيادتها
نعم وصل وزير الخارجيه السعودي قبل قليل
من الان الى مطار العاصمه العراقيه بغداد
وكان باستقباله وزير الخارجيه العراقي
وكذلك السفير السعودي لدى العراق سينتقل
بعد ذلك الى المنطقه الخضراء لعقد لقاء
مطول مع نظيره العراق من خلال اجتماع
الوفد السعودي والوفد العراقي على ان يكون
هناك مؤتمرا صحفيا مقتضى بن الوزيرين
للحديث عن العلاقات السعوديه العراقيه وما
تم البحث فيه خلال هذه الزياره ومن ثم
سيجري زياره اي وزير الخارجيه السعودي
للرئاسات الثلاث رئيس الحكومه ورئيس
الجمهوريه ورئيس البرلمان سيتم بحث الكثير
من النقاط الموجوده في اطار المجلس
التنسيقي العراقي السعودي الذي يتضمن ثمان
رجال لجان سياسيه وامنيه واقتصاديه
وتجاريه وكذلك
اجتماعيه ومن ثم سيقوم ايضا بالحديث حول
التطورات في الملتقى في العراق يسعى من
خلال هذه الزياره لكي يكون هناك بحث او
انطلاق المباحثات التي كان العراق قد
تبناها ما بين الرياض وطهران خلال السنوات
القليله الماضيه العراق يسعى من هذه
الزياره لكي تكون هناك حوار ثاني ما بين
المملكه وطهران ايضا سيتم بحث العلاقات
العراقيه السعوديه في مجمل القضايا التي
طرحت من خلال المجلس التنسيقي العراقي
السعودي هناك ايضا نقطه مهمه بان هذه
الزياره الاولى لوزير الخارجيه السعودي في
ظل حكومه رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد اشياء
السودانيه ايضا كان هناك وفد اجتمع ما بين
الجانب العراقي والجانب السعودي في منفذ
عرعر ومن خلال تم الاعلان عن زياده عدد
المعتمرين من الف معتمر يوميا الى 5000
معتمر عبر هذا المنفذ ايضا سيتم بحث ملفات
اقليميه من خلال الاجتماع الذي سيعقد بين
الامير فيصل بن فرحان وكذلك فؤاد حسين
فؤاد حسين كان لديه تصريحات لقناه العربيه
قبل يومين من هذه الزياره اشاد بالعلاقه
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه ووصف هذا
العلاقه بالقويه والمتينه كذلك سيتم بحث
عدد من المشاريع التي كانت قسمت فيها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومنها الملعب
الاوروبي الكبير الذي اهدي من قبل المملكه
العراق سيتم ايضا بحث اين المكان تخصيص
المكان الذي سيتم من خلاله بناء هذا
الملعب وكذلك تم انشاء عدد من المستشفيات
من قبل الجانب السعودي من خلال
القرض الذي تم الذي تم اعطائه من قبل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه خلال مؤتمر
الكويت لاعماره العراق وخاصه في محافظه
الانبار وكذلك اعاده ترميم مستشفى ابن
الخطيب على حساب المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ايضا سيتم تحديد موعد انطلاق جلسه جديده
للمجلس التنسيقي بين العراق والرياض وبحث
ملفات اخرى خاصه بان هناك زياره مرتقبه
لوزير الخارج وزير الداخليه العراقي الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وكذلك زياره
اخرى خلال الشهر القادم الى كذلك لوزير
الدفاع العراقي الى المملكه
فالسؤال سريع ماجد متى من المتوقع ان يبدا
هذا المؤتمر الصحفي المرتقب هذا المساء
نعم سينتقل الوفد من مطار بغداد ويحتاج
تقريبا الى 15 دقيقه للوصول الى مقر وزاره
الخارج يوم ثم سيكون هناك اجتماع ربما
يمتد لاكثر من نصف ساعه بين الجانب
العراقي والوفد السعودي بعد ذلك سيكون
هناك مؤتمر مقتضب للحديث عن نتائج هذا
الاجتماع وما سيتم بحثه مع الرئاسات
الثلاث هناك ايضا نقطه مهمه بان البرلمان
العراقي كان قد اقر قراءه اولى لقانون
حمايه الاستثمار ما بين المملكه والعراق
ايضا سيتم مناقشه هذا الموضوع من قبل وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه خلال لقائه برئيس
البرلمان العراقي محمد الحلبوسي واضح شكرا
لك من بغداد مراسل العربيه ماجد حميد على
كل هذه المعلومات
الى التهديدات الايرانيه لدول الجوار
وايضا الملاحه الدوليه حيث اكدت القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه اعتراض شحنه اسلحه
ايرانيه كانت متجهه الى اليمن في الخامس
عشر من يناير الماضي وكانت صحيفه
المشاهدين تحدثت عن عمليه مشتركه مع
البحريه الفرنسيه لمصادره الاسلحه
الايرانيه اما القياده المركزيه الامريكيه
فقد اشارت الى مصادره صواريخ موجهات غطاء
الدبابات كانت ايران تنقلها الى الحوثي
ويبلغ عددها 23 صاروخا واكدت القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه مصادره 3000 بندقيه
ايرانيه ونصف مليون طلقه كانت في طريقها
الى الحوثي وقالت صحيفه وولز جورنال
بدورها ان العمليه الفرنسيه ضد الحوثي ضمن
مخطط لاحتواء انشطه ايران التخريبيه كما
اكدت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه اعتراض
اربعه عمليات تهريب اسلحه ايرانيه خلال
الشهرين الماضيين
شحنات الاسلحه المهربه تكادلات تتوقف في
اتجاه جماعه الحوث في اليمن مره اخرى في
خليج عمان البحريه الفرنسيه تضبط زورقا
يضم اكثر من ثلاثه الاف بندقيه فضلا عن
نصف مليون رصاصه وعشرين صاروخا مضادا
للدبابات
العمليه جاءت في وقت اصبحت باريس ولندن
تلعبان دورا اكبر في عمليه التصدي لتهريب
الاسلحه في المنطقه بعد ان تصدرت واشنطن
المهمه
المتحدث باسم الاسطول الخامس الامريكي
تيموثيوكانز اكد ان الجيش الامريكي ساعد
في مصادره الشحنه
وخلال شهرين تمكنت واشنطن وشركائها من منع
وصول اكثر من 5000 قطعه سلاح ومليون
وستمائه الف طلقه ذخيره الى اليمن البحريه
الامريكيه كانت قد صادرت اكثر من 2000
بندقيه منقارب في خليج عمان كانت متجهه
الى جماعه الحوثي اضافه الى مخدرات تبلغ
قيمتها 33 مليون دولار من سفينه صيد في
المياه الدوليه في خليج عمان الشحنات
المهربه من الاسلحه الى اليمن ليست والده
اليوم في ديسمبر الماضي اعلنت البحريه
الاميركيه مصادره 1400 بندقيه من طراز
47 من على متن سفينه صيد شماليه بحر العرب
كانت قادمه من ايران كما صدرت اكثر من
مليون ومئه الف طلقه من سفينه صيد تعمل
بين ايران واليمن
فمنذ انقلاب ميليشيات الحوث في اليمن
اواخر عام 2014 كسفت ايران عمليات تهريب
الاسلحه جوا وبرا وبحرا وعبر كل المنافذ
بلال البجدين العربيه
على توسعات الوجود العسكريه الامريكي
اوكرانيا تشن معركه داخليه ضد الفساد
يعترف بصعوبه الوضع على جبهات القتال
[موسيقى]
روسيا تحتفل بذكرى هزيمه الالمان ورئيس
المخابرات يقول لن نحارب حتى اخر اوكراني
طهران تنشر سفينتين عسكريتين في البرازيل
و واشنطن تراقب تحركات ايران في امريكا
اللاتينيه
وسط مخاوف متزايده بشان التوغل الصيني
واشنطن لا توسعان الوجود العسكري في
الفلبين
احييكم من جديد البدايه من وزير الدفاع
الامريكي وتصريحاته حيث قال ان التزام
الولايات المتحده بالدفاع عن الفلبين صارم
مشددا على ان واشنطن لا تسعى لاقامه قواعد
دائمه في الفلبين بل معالجه الانشطه
المزعزعه للاستقرار اما بخصوص تهديد كوريا
الشماليه فقد افاد اوستن ان هدف امريكا
الاول هو زياده الامن والاستقرار في
المنطقه مؤكدا العمل مع الحلفاء بشكل دائم
للتاكد من وجود قوات ذات مصداقيه في
المنطقه اما فيما يخص اوكرانيا بين اوستن
ان الولايات المتحده بدلت ما بوسعها
لمساعده اوكرانيا لتصبح فعاله قبل الهجوم
المضاد في الربيع اما وزاره الدفاع
الفلبينيه فقد افادت بان مانيلا وافقت
للولايات المتحده على الوصول الى قواعدها
العسكريه والصمخاوف متزايده بشان توغل
الصين المتزايد في بحر الصين الجنوبي
والمتنازع عليه والتوترات حول تايوان طبعا
اما بحسب الوزاره سيتم من حواسطه كذلك حق
الوصول الى اربعه مواقع اخرى في مناطق
استراتيجيه من البلاد تحت اتفاقيه تعاون
دفاعي يعود تاريخها الى 2014
وفي قضيه تيك توك التي تثير الجدل في
الولايات المتحده اعلن النائب الجمهوري
مايك جلاجر بعد قضايا مهمه مع المسؤول عن
امن البيانات والمعلومات في تيك توك بينها
خطط وامان البيانات الامريكيه لتطبيق
الفيديو والقصير المملوك للصين في وقت لا
تزال مساعي مجلس النواب الامريكي تتجه نحو
حظر تيك توك في الولايات المتحده
المصرف المركزي البريطاني مشاهدينا اعلن
ان صور ملوك بريطانيا ستختفي من الاوراق
النقديه في استراليا من فئه الخمسه
دولارات القرار هذا يعني ان صوره الملك
تولز الثالث لن توضع على العمله الورقيه
الاستراليه من فئه الخمسه دولارات البنك
الاحتياطي الاسترالي بدوره قال انه سيتم
استشاره السكان الاصليين بشان تصميم جديد
موضحا ان تصميمه وطباعه الاوراق النقديه
الجديده سيستغرق سنوات وستبقى الاوراق
النقديه التي تحمل صوره الملكه الراحله
المتداوله قانونيه حتى يتحقق ذلك
في شان الفلك والفضاء لاحظ علماء فلك
مذنبا اخضر من مرصدهم على قمه تل جنوب وسط
اليونان اثناء وميضه في السماء ليلا كان
المذنب الذي ظل كاملا في سماء الليل لاشهر
يمر بالقرب من الارض للمره الاولى منذ
حوالي خمسين الف عام يذكر انه يتم اكتشافه
اقل من 12 مذنبا كل عام بواسطه المراصد
حول العالم معلم
يمني سابق لجا في تعز الى ممارسه هوايته
الفنيه المتمثله في تلحين اغاني شعبيه
ساخره تنتقد الوضع المعيشي المتدهور جراء
الحرب الحوثيه وذلك لتحصيل ما يسد به رمقه
[موسيقى]
اذا معك لحمه ورشوش
بطرب شعبي ومن كوخ اتخذه بديلا عن منزله
يلخص الثقافه حول التعليم في البلد
فالثقاف الذي علم اجيالا ماده اللغه
العربيه وسرح من وظيفته قبل 18 عاما يجد
اليوم نفسه ملقيا على الرصيف في وضع معيشي
ونفسي بدا اكثر تعقيدا نتيجه الحرب
الحوثيه انا ساكن في ذلك الكوخ لاني لا
امتلك اي اي مكان اخر غير هذا
فكان تلك ذلك الكوخ هو الوسيله التي
تحميني من المطار والشمس ومن عوامل الطقس
المختلفه كيف تم هذا الجو فتره الى ما قبل
الحرب والاحداث التي حصلت كانت الامور عاد
تمشي معانا
كيف مع المصادر من بعد الحرب تقلقت كل
الابواب استوطن الرصيفه اذا وقبل به
فاعتمد كليا على اله العود على ان يقتات
منها بشرف يقول الرجل وتاره اخرى ينتقد
الوضع من امام مكتب التربيه والتعليم لعل
رسائله على الاوتار هذه توقظ اذهان
المعنيين لتصحيحه وضع المعلمين
زميلنا صبري السقاف الشاعر وكاتب وملحن
وعازف ومغنن وكاتب سيناريو له كثير من
الاسهامات في حياتنا اليوميه التي نتابعها
له في السابق اغاني وطنيه كثيره حاليا له
غانم انتقد فيها الوضع المعيشي ومرحله
الياس والاحباط التي وصل اليها المجتمع
اليمني
ليس الثقاف وحده من بات اليوم يشكو ضنك
المعيشه على ارصفه الشوارع بل تمت العشرات
من المعلمين يعيشون الوضع نفسه خصوصا مع
ارتفاع الاسعار وانقطاع الرواتب وتدهور
الوضع المعيشي في البلد يزداد الوضع
المعيشي تعقيدا في البلد ويضيق الخناق على
اكثر من 40 الف معلم ومعلم في المدينه هذه
امر بات يهدد باحتضار التعليم خصوصا مع
افتقار الطلبه للكتاب المدرسي وعزوف
غالبيه المعلمين عن المدارس والانخراط
باعمال اخرى كالسلك العسكري لاعاله اسرهم
هل سعيد العربيه تعز
في تظاهرات فنيه سعوديه خليجيه عربيه كبرى
شاركه اكثر من 40 فنانا وفنانا في تكريم
الفنان السعودي الراحل طلال مداح على مسرح
محمد عبده ارينا في الرياض وضمن ليله صوت
الارض بمبادره من رئيس هيئه الترفيف
السعوديه تركي ال الشيخ نتابع
[موسيقى]
اكثر من اربعين فنانا من ثلاثه عشره دوله
عربيه صعدوا على المسرح في ليله واحده
تكريما للفنان السعودي طلال مداح الذي رحل
قبل اكثر من 22 عاما وبعد اكثر من نصف قرن
من عطائه الفني لا يزال راسخا في ذاكره
عشاقه في السعوديه وعموم العالم العربي
اعمده كثيره في الفن السعودي طلال مداح
احد الاعمده المه سعودي اذا جينا نؤرخ
للفن للغناء بالذات
والغناء جزء مهم من الفن يعني فنؤرح من
عند طلال مداح
[موسيقى]
ليله صوت الارض الحدث الفني الاضخم عربيا
وعالميا اقيمت في الرياض برعايته الترفيه
السعوديه بحضور الالاف من الجماهير التي
ما زالت تردد اغنيه الراحل حتى يومنا هذا
ومن مختلف الاعمار
الشيخ فطاربي واتحادي فكان يحسبني ولد عبد
المحسن الشيخ الداعم الاتحاد طلعنا غلبان
وقاعد يضحك وحضني اسمحوا لي اغني اغنيه
بالعود بهذا العود اللي احتفظت ابوه 22
سنه وهو الاستاذ طلال
ما هذا اقود
وقد فيكي
[موسيقى]
هذه الليله جاءت بعد مبادره رئيس الهيئه
السعوديه للترفيه تركي ال الشيخ الذي قدم
قبل اسابيع دعوه مفتوحه لكل نجوم السعوديه
والخليج والعالم العربي للمشاركه وهو ما
قبل باستجابه اكبر عدد من الفنانين
والفنانات سعوديا وخليجيا وعربيا انتم
ابناء فنان عظيم من حقكم انكم ترفعون
راسكم في بلدكم اليوم في تكريم ابوكم
يا عمر
شافوني مشغل طلال مداح
فكلن يطلع من عندي واحد يكلمني يعني
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
اوكرانيا تشن معركه داخليه ضد الفساد
يعترف بصعوبه الوضع على جبهات القتال
روسيا تحتفل بذكرى هزيمه الالمان ورئيس
المخابرات يقول لن نحارب حتى اخر اوكراني
طهران تنشر سفينتين عسكريتين في البرازيل
وواشنطن تراقب تحركات ايران في امريكا
اللاتينيه
دمتم بخير
[موسيقى]